[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday as you
will no doubt notice I am wearing my
nerd glasses again Hank the nerd glasses
got pretty bad reviews when I pulled him
out the first time including he looks
like he's trying to be emo but he's too
old to which I have this response if I'm
too old to be emo how do you account for
the very emo and very old Edgar Allan
Poe checkmate
but I might go back and forth between
these glasses and my other glasses for
the rest of the year Hank in other news
as you can see over there I've moved my
writing setup into my office I did this
because for the last several days I've
been working like 16 hours a day in a
big ocean of paper in the living room
and then finally the ocean of paper
actually took over the living room and
so to escape the ocean of paper I had to
move into the office but I have good
news Hank I finished the most recent
revision of Paper Towns Hank usually in
this kind of situation I would do my
happy dance but I'm just so tired I feel
kind of like my brain has turned into
liquid and like at any moment my brain
might start to drip out of my nose or
would it drip out of my ears
Hank that sounds like a good challenge
for the nerdfighters nerdfighters if my
brain were to liquefy would it come out
of my eyes or out of my nose or out of
my ears or out of some combination of
the three
Hank usually I would think that's the
kind of question that has no answer but
I have recently learned not to
underestimate the nerdfighters by the
way nerdfighters I will deliver you your
handsome reward before the end of the
year in some fashion or another do you
think that was brain do you think
there's a chance that that was brain
that I just shot back up into my brain
and that for the rest of my life every
five minutes or so I'm just gonna have
to be like you know just to keep my
brain up there oh my god Hank something
just occurred to me what if amy
winehouse doesn't have a drug problem
she just has a liquefied brain and so
she has to snort every few minutes to
get her brain back into her head
no wonder she had to cancel all her
concerts for the rest of the year she
has liquid brain I'd cancel my concerts
too all right Hank I'm starting to worry
that if I talk to you any longer I'm
going to give you in the nerdfighters
liquid brain so I'm gonna sign off now
oh one more thing Hank on Friday I want
to talk about Christmas but I was
thinking maybe early next week I could
answer some questions from nerdfighters
the questions can be about anything I
mean they can be about Pakistan or they
can be about my glasses or whatever
anyway nerdfighters if you have any
questions of any kind please feel free
to leave them down there Hank
I'll see you tomorrow hey scavenger
hunters you've already received today's
clue